un mot de musique on a appris
aujourd'hui la mort du chanteur mano
solo mort à l'âge de 46 ans il souffrait
du sida depuis de nombreuses années il
avait une voix déchirante un talent
multiple
il aimait le tango la poésie le dessin
il était encore en concert à l'olympia
le 12 novembre dernier
mano solo qui parlait également toujours
clairement et sincèrement écouter un au
solo c'est un peu ça c'est à dire que
personne me sortir de mon merdias par
mois moi je veux rappeler aux gens
aujourd'hui que tout ce qu'on a à chuter
à gagner à aujourd'hui à se shooter
s'est chopé le sida ou ou toute manière
c'est une perte de temps que c'est ça
j'ai envie de dire aux gens et surtout
aux jeunes parce que c'est vraiment une
perte de temps de se défoncer la gueule
aujourd'hui
tout en restant dans les joues roses
avant
qu'il propose
voilà le solo mort à l'âge de 46 ans